- All right. Two, one.
Woo! All right, we can finally start.
But even though you guys have
been here for like 15 minutes,
it feels like already,
so you must be really
excited about this session.
But if you've already been using Kiro,
I don't know how much of this
is necessarily gonna be new information
because well, if you're a practitioner
and you're playing with it daily,
you're gonna get a lot
of information already.
Also, I bought these
shoes today and if I fall,
I want my CSAT scores to
be like super high, okay.
I need the sympathy vote. Whoa.
All right. So, my name is Rory Richardson.
I am joined by Vidhear from Delta Airlines
and Sam, who's a solution
architect focused on Kiro.
And what we're gonna
do is we're gonna talk
a little bit about like,
the preface of the, where,
how we got here in the
evolution of agentic AI.
Then we're gonna talk about the importance
of spec-driven development
in relationship vibe coding.
We're gonna do a quick
introduction to Kiro,
and then we're gonna get some
real world tactical experience
by talking about how Delta Airlines
has been incorporating Kiro
into their software development lifecycle
and eventually their AI
development lifecycle.
And then lastly, we're
gonna wrap up with a demo.
The demo is coming in
pretty hot, as you know,
we've made a lot of announcements
yesterday morning in Garman's keynote.
Did y'all see Garman's keynote?
Raise your hand. Yeah.
Was it good? Yeah.
One of my favorite parts
is the autonomous agents
that we're introducing
because it greatly expands the context
and the ability of combining
multiple agents together
in order to do more
and more complex tests.
It's a very foundational concept
that I think is going to continue to grow
over the next six months, year.
I think more and more folks
are going to do more
and more complex things
with the agents themselves
and combining them for
the autonomous agents
to be able to orchestrate, monitor,
and even verify the work
of other agents to build them together.
So let's talk a little bit
about the agentic mindset,
because there are a few things
that we've learned like,
oh, probably the last
two years or 18 months,
when I would talk with a lot of customers,
usually they would come with an idea
or a business problem
that they wanted to solve.
But unfortunately a lot of
folks started with like really,
really hard problems and things
that were customer facing
and things that were about
the core competency of the business.
Like, great, we're gonna
get AI to do the very thing
that we sell to our customers.
Uh-huh. The problem is that's
taking on the most risk.
Right, and especially if
you haven't done one before,
why take on the most amount of risk?
Instead, the companies
that we've seen to be
the most agentic in nature
are starting with the muck.
I was talking to this business consultant
a year and a half ago from
Boston Consulting Group
and he said, "Rory,
generative AI is fabulous.
It can make music."
The problem is nobody wants it to.
What they want is for
it to go do the dishes
so that you can go off and make music.
So where we are seeing
the most exponential value
out of the application of generative AI
and agentic AI is removing toil and muck
to free humans up to be human.
Now, it means a lot of
developers are like, "Oh my god,
you know, AI's coming for my job."
How many thinks AI's coming for your job?
Raise your hands. Right, just you.
I don't, Gartner said it
best when they said that
AI is probably not coming
for your developers,
but a developer using AI is
probably coming for a developer
that is not using AI.
And I think that's kind of a true thing
because a lot of agents, I kind of view as
various ages of children, right?
You know, they have
really great ideas like,
"Oh, let me tell you, let me help you,
let me help you, let me help you."
And I was like, "No, I don't
trust you to touch the dishes.
You're too young."
So how we are dealing with the agents
depends on the level of sophistication
and how much we trust the information
that we're getting back from them
before we incorporate it
into what we're doing.
Because you're not gonna fire AI,
but I will fire a developer
if they, you know,
write bad code or malicious code
or introduce risk into the application.
Yeah, these are all things,
the humans are still responsible, y'all,
this is super important.
But can a developer be augmented?
I mean, think about all
the muck that you do
in your software development
lifecycle, right?
Who loves Jira?
Raise your hand. Yeah.
(Rory exhaling)
Jira something, (imitating buzzing)
but being able to search through
Jira, automate, you know,
Jira tickets and being able
to optimize that experiment
and will give everybody
else here a better day.
Because it's not, when
you're messing with Jira,
you're not creating that new application.
Because you know, when you
first started being a developer
you wanted to do, you wanted
to make cool stuff, right?
So everything that is not helping
you make cool stuff, muck.
So, quick history lesson,
I know you're all on this journey with us,
but we started off with plugins
into the existing IADEs,
vs code and you know,
JetBrains, intelligent.
And that seemed like a really great idea.
And then we got this idea like,
wouldn't it be cool if we made agents
that go off and do bespoke tasks
within the software development lifecycle,
like slash review or slash doc?
This was great, except we were
teaching a bunch of people
how to work with agents
and not teaching the agents
to work with the people.
How many of you have a smartphone,
like an iPhone or something?
Yeah, and do you remember
that you, you know,
were told specifically you
had to use that device,
how to optimize it, and then
you had to take a, you know,
an enablement session to fully use it.
Of course not.
It's just, you just get started
and you get to choose
whatever device that you want.
That's the developer experience, right?
So instead of teaching developers
or anyone how to interact the technology,
we should have the opposite approach.
And one of the ways we're able to do that
is to have an agentic AI
approach to software development.
So now, instead of having
just plugins into the IDE,
we've seen the rise of agentic
IDs and this was great.
I mean vibe coding school,
right? You just get started.
How many's had to debug
one of your colleague's
vibe coding projects?
Yeah, super fun, right?
(Rory laughing)
But it's also kind of an anti-pattern.
I mean, first of all, the democratization
of people being able to create something
just through natural language is,
it was the dream of low-code, no-code.
It's always been the dream.
Like, how do I, can I just prototype this?
How do I just get started? It was great.
But then how do to work
with other developers
to do more and more complex things?
And that's combining
spec-driven development
with vibe coding to accelerate.
How are you getting something, you know,
from prototype into production?
The other change that we've seen this year
is the rise of protocols for
agent to agent communication.
How many of you people are
using MCP servers? Right?
Wasn't that way last year.
I mean, this is a radical change
in how we're thinking
about the very architecture
of agents themselves.
So, earlier this year I was like, well,
what is the definition of an agent?
Because if you look on the
internet, no one could agree.
Like you get, you know,
three people together,
they would have all different definitions
of what an agent was.
So we're gonna go with my definition
because I'm the one with the mic.
I started out with, well,
it has to be able to form
tasks asynchronously.
It has to go off and come back.
It has to have some degree of autonomy.
It has to have agency.
And I mean that in a very pride
and prejudice sense, right?
It has to be able to make
some decisions on its own.
But this last idea, this last idea
of adding the word atomic is fairly new
and the most controversial.
And yeah, they all start
with a, I did that.
Atomic is meaning that you're able
to make more bespoke agents
and then combine these
bespoke smaller agents
in different ways to do more
and more complex things.
So instead of using a
really, really large model
that has been trained on a
really, really large data set,
what if you could do something
that was more bespoke?
So instead of being good at everything,
what if you could be
great at a few things?
The idea of making atomic agents
kind of brings me back
to my microservices days.
And the idea that you can
combine microservices together
to do more and more complex applications
and also reuse those agents.
This was sort of the
foundational concept behind
what we're trying to do
with autonomous agents.
Being able to use the
right agent for the job,
but not necessarily having to
teach you which agent that is
and when to call it.
These autonomous agents have the ability
to help make those decisions for you.
Now, this kind of feel,
I love a lot of sci-fi.
I'm a huge sci-fi fan,
and it feels almost like
what we really want is Jarvis, right?
Now don't go full ultron, right?
But in "Ironman" one,
Jarvis was a natural language interface
for IoT devices in Tony's house.
By the time you get to "Ironman" three,
Tony is able to go to the holodeck
and go directly into the most humanistic
areas of innovation.
He's able to just start
to vibe code the next Ironman suit.
And then when he's done, he's
able to look over at Jarvis
and said, "All right, now go
off and build the Iron Legion."
Because Jarvis is handling all
the supply chain management
of all of the resources in the house,
managing all the design specs,
managing search within the
libraries of Tony's work.
I mean, can you imagine what the world
is going to be like when
your kids have access
to that level of assistance
for anything that they want to make?
That's the world that we're living in.
I mean, I have a 15-year-old
and I've been trying to teach this kid
to code since he was four.
I can't get those 10 years back
because what is the role of Python
by the time that kid hits the job market?
I mean the syntax is
kind of taken care of.
I'm not saying computer science is dead
by any stretch of the imagination,
but the world has dramatically changed
for how our children
are going to interface
with solutions and innovation.
And it's not about agents per se,
it's about how fast and
how hard can they dream
because they're gonna be able to create it
with the assistance of these tools.
So we created an agentic IDE like hero
that married the idea of vibe coding
with traditional spec-driven development.
This also changed a lot of the roles
within our two pizza teams at AWS,
it's been highly disruptive
because now we move much
faster when we embed our PMs
into those teams because we're able
to iterate on the specs much, much faster.
So, engineering reaches a problem.
They were like, "Hey,
this isn't gonna work."
PM takes it and goes, "Yep,
let's rewrite, you know,
the direction of what we're going."
And that entire process is, hey,
it takes a matter of hours and not weeks.
This level of speed has
created other problems
because the number of code
commits that we're able to do,
test wasn't ready for it.
QA, wasn't ready for it.
There's downstream impacts to the speed
that we're able to get things done now.
So having an AI IDE
has greatly accelerated
well, everything that we touch at AWS
because, and at Amazon.
You can view Amazon as like
our first best worst customer,
'cause they know where we sit
and they come and they
give us direct feedback
and we have to compete for
their developer time as well
in order to figure out like,
what is the tools that we
should be creating internally.
And so, that's our own internal test bed
in order to refine like,
some of our thinking
and what we decided to build.
Also, we found tremendous uptick
of the command line interface.
The command line interface,
we found a lot of people were using it
or weren't necessarily having an IDE
already installed on their computer.
That means this is a
different type of user
that is using the command line interface
to do different tasks,
but also these tasks are associated with
the software development lifecycle.
So we incorporated the
command line interface
also into Kiro.
And so now Kiro is also
available in the terminal.
This evolution of agentic AI
has changed everything
about what we're doing,
and it continues to accelerate
exactly how we're creating software,
not only from just a traditional
application development,
but also how we're creating
the agents themselves.
Now, I got my roots in microservices
and breaking up monolithic
architectures into microservices.
I've been talking with customers lately
that aren't doing that anymore,
because that's so 2022.
Now they're thinking
about breaking up monolith
into true agentic architecture
and bypassing that step.
So the foundation of these
applications are agentic.
And so the process of creating agents
has fundamentally changed and accelerated.
You'll hear a lot about the tools
that we are developing to enable that,
whether it's a framework like Strands SDK
or an agentic platform like Agent Core
that gives you the building blocks for,
you know, runtime and memory,
but also choosing the right
inference for your job.
But the thing that I think is
the most interesting is data.
Because now if you're
able to create an agent
that is directly
responsible for your data,
the responses that you're going to get
are more bespoke to your environment.
So the ability to create these agents
in combination with the full tool chain,
well, I'm really excited
to see what's next
and what people are going to create.
I've been working really
closely with Delta
because Delta has a mindset
that is agentic architecture in nature.
When they started sharing
some of their architecture diagrams,
I was super impressed with
how they were thinking about
those autonomous agents
and what do you call 'em?
Nano agents or sub-agents?
- Sub-agents.
And that made me feel really old
because in my architecture diagram
there was a load balancer,
there was EC2 and theirs is different.
So they're trying to push the
envelope of what's possible
in the safest possible way
that scales within an
enterprise organization.
So with that, I'd like to invite Vidhear
to talk about their experience
and how they've applied it
directly to Delta Airlines.
Come on up. You are not gonna catch me.
I swear, we're not gonna
trust fall. I'm gonna be fine.
- I'm gonna be (indistinct).
- I'm gonna live up to my word.
I'm here to catch you.
- No, it's gonna be fine.
No, no.
- Okay.
(Vidhear laughs)
Before I begin, how many of you
flew on Delta to reach here,
this amazing conference?
That's good. Thank you for
your business, genuinely.
And for those who use the
free wifi in our flights
to finish the last minute work
or prepare flights like
me, you are welcome.
Delta is the first airline in the US
that introduced free
wifi across our flights.
We are the pioneers of
innovation and technology
in entire airline industry.
Hundred years of legacy and
history that we created.
Now, decisions like this are
made behind a philosophy that,
which I would like to share with you all,
is we'd like to create
experience for our customers,
the best experience
possible for our customers,
and make it as the new standard
and execute it every day.
And that is the philosophy
that we follow in every domain
and every group in Delta,
even in developer experience,
which we lead and serve
for our Delta developers,
we follow the same philosophy.
We would like to provide the best tools
and technology for our developers
so that we can reduce their friction
and improve their innovation every day.
Rory shared great vision
on the agentic roadmap
that AWS is getting into,
and it aligns very much with our vision
and the roadmap that we
are planning as well.
How many of you had seen slides like this
and started preparing mental mapping of
how to adjust my roadmap?
Which things I need to
prioritize and deprioritize?
I'll raise my both hands
because every tech
conference that I visited,
every exec we reached out to,
whenever they share something,
immediately we started
mapping how to adjust,
which changes we need to make.
But here is what we learned that
we can achieve this autonomy
agentic architecture by building on trust,
the trust from our developer community.
With the rollout of Q Developer
on the left hand side,
the coding assistance,
Q Developer is fully
adopted in entire Delta.
Almost every developer uses Q Developer
and they are giving great feedback.
It laid that foundation.
In the middle, what we have
Kiro, IDE, the agentic IDE,
which we are scaling now
across the Delta enterprise,
and we are marching towards
the autonomous agentic systems,
which are going to be integrated
into our developer workflows.
And with the help of Q Developers so far,
what we gained was we were able to capture
the major wins that Q Developer provided
and also helped us to understand,
what are the areas of improvement?
What are the automations that we can build
for our developers?
So, to increase this adoption
and get to the stage that we want,
we created a model, right?
One thing that we didn't try was,
we didn't try to convince
all of our thousands of
developers in one session,
not at the goal, right?
It is not possible.
At the same time, we are not staffed up
to reach out and talk to
each and every developer.
So what we did was, with the
support of our leadership,
we reached out to all
of our domain leaders
and asked them, nominate
some of the champions
who are technically and
technologically very sound
and very trustworthy
and they can influence
the developer community
without any title and authority, right?
With the trust.
So with the help of these dev champions,
we are able to scale this model.
We went domain by domain,
we trained each domain
and also we build the trainer model.
Because these days
everyone knows AI, right?
When Rory was sharing that
the technology is always like technology,
how it's gonna help for
our children in future,
that immediately reminded me
a personal experience at my home as well.
Few weeks back I was, I
have a 7-year-old daughter.
So I asked her just casually,
two simple math problems, multiplication.
I gave her try these out. So
she took, "Okay, I'll try."
Five minutes back, she came back
and asked, "Can I use chat GPT?"
I'm not making this up.
It's really happened.
I was really shocked.
I was like, "I'm really surprised.
Where did you heard about Chat GPT?"
I was expecting maybe you're gonna ask me
can I use calculator to do this?
And she was like, "What is a calculator?"
See, the AI advancements
are happening very fast
that everyone knows how to
use AI, how to adopt them.
But the most important
thing is inputs to this AI,
the inference that we are
gonna provide to this AI.
Because everyone knows, like I said,
everything, AI is an amplifier.
So the more structured prompts,
the more context we provide,
the more guardrails we introduce,
we are gonna get the best output
that everyone is looking for.
At the same time, if we have chaos,
it's gonna amplify that chaos.
So that's why we focus a lot
on setting those inputs right.
Getting our community ready so
that we can scale this model.
Now these dev champions, this
is not their primary job.
They have their their day jobs.
They need to work in their
sprints and scrum models.
So when we reached out
and formed this community,
we clearly said we wanted to
clearly set the expectations
because we want to approach
this outcome based, right?
So we clearly said that this
is what we expect from you.
We want you to participate
in the initial session
so that you can know, learn how to train,
how to train your teams.
We need you to participate
in our office hours
so that you can help others
and also listen to their questions.
And we need you to
contribute your prompts,
any prompts that you
worked and we need you
to bring along your entire
team, not just developers,
your product owners, scrum
masters, how to use Q Developer.
They helped us to reach
almost every developer
in entire Delta IT, which is the best part
that any email campaign or
marketing campaign could do
because nobody reads emails.
That's the fact, right?
So using the dev champions, we were able
to establish that community
and able to scale this model
and increase the Q Developer adoption.
But we started seeing that
developers are writing code.
We started seeing that more,
we're writing more code much faster,
but still we're not
able to see the result.
What is the end result?
What is the outcome that is aligning
with our business expectations?
So this is the pivotal moment,
which is the very important part.
The feedback that we got
from our developers is,
it is very important to understand
that moving from help
me write this function,
to help me build this feature.
We need AI that understands
the business context,
our governance, our compliance
rules, our integrations.
It needs to understand all of those.
Then only we can get to the stage of
delivering the feature level output.
That is when Kiro entered into our story.
So we partnered with our AWS team
and we are one of the
early pilot users of Kiro.
We introduced it to our, again,
our same champions community
and also some power users of Q Developer.
And we asked them, go ahead and use Kiro
and start giving us your feedback.
Because we already built
their trust, right?
When we rolled out the Q Developer,
we started to gain their trust
and they started giving
us responding feedback
in the form of feedback.
Four main themes that
evolved from their feedback.
They clearly said that using
Kiro versus any other tool,
we are able to see that it can understand
our complex code base, our business rules,
our existing logic and extract it
and build the context
that it is expecting.
At the same time, they clearly
said that it was able to
break down the given requirement
to easily implement a
design and executable task.
And most important thing,
we started seeing that Kiro,
with the help of Kiro,
we are able to build
production ready code.
I want to underline that,
No two enterprises will have
the same set of governance
and compliance rules to
build their products.
So it is very important
a tool to understand,
establish the context and
adjust and deliver the code
that is production ready
and ready to deploy into
the higher environments,
which we are able to see using Kiro.
We also heard feedback from our architects
and some of the developers
that they were able to use Kiro
to be a critic in their
architecture decisions.
They use, some of them
use that as a soundboard
to validate that is my
design and approach,
is it correct or not?
That is the most exciting part.
So we started seeing that Kiro becoming
one of the team member who
has this beautiful memory
of memorizing the thousand lines of code,
establishing the context,
at the same time, giving
you advices and suggestions,
which direction you need to go
for your next product
and next implementation.
That is the most exciting
part we started seeing
and we started realizing
with the help of Kiro.
And the spec-driven
development is the most unique
and innovative feature that
we came across in Kiro.
Simple. It's not that complex.
Three simple step, step
one, lock your requirements,
to give you a detailed requirements.
Step two, Kiro automatically
breaks down your requirements
and start building the
design, generating the design.
And step three, it will
also give you the tasks,
giving power to the developers.
That is the most important
part, human in the loop.
Ultimately, developers has the power,
whether they accept the design
or they're gonna execute those tasks
or they're gonna give refine
or alter any direction
that Kiro needs to implement those.
So we started seeing that
level of flexibility,
at the same time, context awareness.
And the most important
part, the backlog grooming.
How many of you familiar with
this? I see a lot of nods.
Everyone, right? Backlog, grooming.
Several hours of backlog grooming,
lot of debates about story points,
definition of done, acceptance criteria
and lot of feelings get hurt.
And so much, so much drama, right?
So what we started to, this is the thing
that we'd never expected
when we introduced Kiro
to our pilot users.
They start, they transformed
this backlog grooming days
into Kiro spec design days.
Kiro spec design sessions.
So they used that time to
refine the requirements.
They started with Kiro
instead of backlog grooming,
they started with Kiro
with their requirements
and gave Kiro the prompt in a way
that this is the format we create
our features and use the stories.
And this is the, this is our model
we would like you to create accordingly.
They started seeing those results.
And those sessions, because
Kiro can remember the context
and it can automatically
adjust based on your code base.
The amount of time even
to do the spec refinement
is also getting shorter and shorter.
And surprisingly no one
complained that petition
to bring back those
backlog rooming session.
We'll take that win.
So, with the pilot, right,
I'm not talking about scaling the Kiro,
we didn't scale the Kiro.
We're getting ready to scale the Kiro.
With just the pilot users, right,
we're able to deliver the first ever
most intelligent developer portal,
end-to-end production ready
meeting all of our compliance
and governance rules.
So, I'm sure many of you are familiar
whenever there is a business
group with the product owners
and there is a technology counterparts,
how much our handoff happens,
how many our meetings we go through,
our business product owners,
they'll create the
mockups, the requirements,
Word document, detailed Word documents,
and God help us some Excel sheets
with all of the requirements, right?
But still, even after all
of this back and forth,
there will be some gaps still
whenever the end result on
the end product is delivered.
So, what we wanted to try out was recently
we trained our business
product owners how to use Kiro.
These are the people who never coded
a single line in their life.
All they did was Word documents, mockups.
So we trained them how to use Kiro.
The end result, they were able to provide
or generate working prototypes,
aligning with the roadmap,
aligning with the new
feature that they wanted.
And they were able to easily
hand off that working prototype
with their technology
counterparts who are easily in,
ours actually integrate with
their working application.
Again, I'm not making this up.
These business product owners said that
the prototype or the design
usually takes us a quarter,
one increment to get that,
and we are able to complete it
in a matter of days and weeks.
It's not only about
the time we are saving,
it is also about fixing those gaps, right?
We started to see that the gap
between the technology team
and the business product
teams getting disappeared
because now everyone started to see
and talk everything in the same language.
No more assumptions, no more imaginations.
Product owners are able to
give the working prototypes
and technology counterparts
are able to immediately visualize
and integrate the actual application.
And like I said, production ready code
is getting delivered every, every time.
And I share with you what we delivered.
At the same time, I
would also like to share
what our developers were saying, right?
Highlighting here three quotes
from the feedback that we
got from our pilot users.
One of the engineering
leader, right, who said that
I forgot my coding practice several years,
but I gave it a try using Kiro.
He said that now I can give tasks to Kiro
and I can go back to my meetings.
In the background,
Kiro is able to continue
to executing those tasks.
And once I'm done with the
meetings and I'm coming back
and refining and reviewing
the code that it generated.
And one of the developers, she said that
spec-driven development stopped me
going circles with vibe coding.
Anyone heard about vibe coding?
Anyone? No.
(Vidhear laughs)
So it is the, I think it's
the official word of the year
for 2025, vibe coding, isn't it?
Lot of prompting, iteration,
prompting, screaming, lot of tears.
We think that there is
a progress being made,
but our committee history will
tell the actual story, right?
So, using Kiro with the
spec-driven development,
what she shared was, it is
remembering the context.
It is giving me the destination,
at the same time the path
to get to that destination,
it is not building code out of vacuum.
The code is getting generated
based on the context.
And one of the senior developers said that
breaking down technical
design into stories
with full repo context.
This is very important, right?
Because there's a lot of,
there will be a lot of freedom
in greenfield development.
If you're starting from
scratch, sky is the limit.
Blue skies, we can make
a lot of assumptions,
a lot of imaginations,
prototyping, all of that.
But if we are implementing
or doing a Brownfield application,
if you have a code that is
written several years back
and it's the most important application,
it's very challenging to plan any changes.
But with the help of Kiro,
they're able to create the work
that needs to be done aligning
with the context of the code.
And 94% of the pilot participants reported
four and greater than four
out of five the feedback.
IDEs are like rifles to the
Marines, to the developers.
There's so much attached.
It is not a simple task asking developers
to try out this new IDE,
but yet all of our
pilot participants were,
because of the trust we built,
they were very open and
flexible and used this
and started giving this great feedback.
And I also shared that Q
Developer the success, right,
that we achieved.
And this is what the trust looks like.
So we launched Q Developer end of March
and the first week of April
and in six months we're able
to achieve 1,948% growth.
That's not a typo,
that's a real percentage.
And I really wish my stock portfolio
gave me this kind of
returns in six months.
Because of the trust that we built
the developers are embracing
any technology that we are building.
And the Q Developer laid that foundations
on those foundations who are getting ready
to scale Kiro across the enterprise.
Of course you need to measure
any of your, any rollout,
any technology enhancements
that you're doing.
Always metrics are very important.
So we created our own dashboard
which helped us to measure
what is the user adoption is looking like,
what is the engagement is looking like.
At the same time, what is
the Q Developer impact?
Which is clearly showed
us that we are able
to produce more code in
the less amount of time.
And again, like I said, the developers,
what they're saying was
primarily it's coming down to,
they're seeing a fundamental
shift in our ways of working.
They're no longer bogged down
or tied to the implementation details
because they were able to give
those implementation details
to Kiro and let it work.
And they are primarily focusing
and a lot of focus on
architecture and design thinking.
And also they're focusing now
to get rid of technical debt, right?
Everyone's favorite word, isn't that?
So they're taking advantage of Kiro
and getting rid of technical debt.
And a lot of use cases we implemented
within this short span
using pilot, pilot group.
So, the takeaway that I would
like to share with you all is
from this pilot experience
and from the adoption of Q Developer
with this agentic AI
tools, developer tools,
we are able to say yes more, now.
I know many of people, leaders here,
you might have read the book,
saying no is very important,
but no, these agentic tools
are helping us to say yes more.
Years worth of backlog, which
got competed and deprioritized
because of competing priorities.
Now we are able to say yes and
start solving those problems.
We are able to bridge the gap
between our business counterparts
and technology counterparts.
And everyone is trying to,
now is able to see the same,
speak the same language,
and see the same outcome.
Now the deliverables are no longer
tied to the size of the team.
They're no longer proportionate.
Smaller teams are starting to
deliver the biggest outcome
with the leveraging tools like Kiro.
And what's next for Delta?
Like I said, we are ready,
we are getting ready to scale
Kiro across our enterprise
and a lot of exciting announcements,
Kiro agents that were announced,
and we're going to integrate
all of the Kiro agents
into our developer
workflows and life cycle.
See, in all of this,
with all this journey,
one thing that our
personal observation is,
the companies in near
future, like a decade or so,
they're gonna win, not just with AI tools,
but when these AI tools are
people are woven together
starting from the build design deployment
from product owners all the
way to production, right?
We need to focus on introducing AI
across the product development life cycle,
which we also call as PDLC.
Because we are Delta,
we allow our acronyms.
So, introducing AI tools and automation
across entire product
development lifecycle
is very important.
Q Developer laid that foundation
and helped to build the trust
among our developer community.
Now we are taking the advantage
and rolling out Kiro for our future.
Now I'm gonna ask Sam to
come up and show some magic
how the Kiro is going
to look like in the IDE.
- Thanks Vidhear. It
was really good to hear.
- [Rory] You're supposed
to clap, his boss is here.
(all laughing)
(audience applauds)
- Nice to hear a practical
experience with the tool here.
So I'm Sam, I'm gonna show
you a quick tour of Kiro here
with a demo that I put together as a video
because there's a lot to show
and it will go pretty quick here.
And so, there'll be some
time lapse that I'll include.
So Kiro is a full featured IDE.
So you'll see a lot of the stuff
that you're kind of used
to seeing in your IDE,
but it's purpose built
for AI agent development.
And as you open it up, you'll see the
spec versus vibe kind of options
here, which is kind of new.
And I'll talk a little bit more about
the spec version of this or features.
But we have some tools included in here
to help you manage your context,
like being able to load files if you want,
grabbing output from your
terminal as you're debugging,
pointing to particular
URLs if you need that.
You can even include images
so that if you have UI
designs or sequence diagrams
or something like that
you want to include,
you can add those.
And you can select the different
agents models you want,
including the latest,
like the Sonic four, five,
we have Opus and there's
this option for auto mode.
The auto mode will let
Kiro automatically pick
which model it's gonna
use, optimal for that.
And it allows you to save a little bit
on the credits as you're
doing it that way.
So it'll pick maybe a model
that might be a little bit cheaper to use
for the particular use
case that it's going after.
On this panel on the left over here
you'll see all the Kiro tools
and these are the things
that are gonna really help
you with your project,
manage the AI agents.
Particularly, we'll start with this,
the steering files component here.
So steering files are a way to give rules
and guidance to the AI.
You can have prompts that
you share amongst your teams
that you might put in there,
coding standards, those kinds of things.
And it'll give Kiro a map
of your code base as well.
So you can click this button here
and Kiro will just automatically
examine your project
if you have a project
that you've already built
and kind of creates these three like,
foundational steering files for it.
One that's just a product file
that describes what the
product is supposed to do,
the features and functions.
It'll create a tech file
that outlines what all
the tech stack that you're
using and a structure file.
So the structure gives it kind
of a map of where files are,
what kind of data you have,
anything that the agent might need to know
so it doesn't have to load
the whole entire code base all the time,
it'll use this to navigate
through your environment.
It also has this feature
with a file match pattern
that you can give it.
So this particular
steering file I have here
is for my UX guidelines
and I'm telling it to only load this
when it's working on HTML or CSS files.
And that way this doesn't get
into my context all the time
because too much context can
confuse the AI agent here.
These are just MD files,
so you can source them with your project,
you can share them.
Of course with Kiro we can manage MCP,
but if you go to kiro.dev
you'll find that we
have a directory of MCPs
that we recommend that are
easy to just with a click
you get them added to your project.
And we'll take that a step
further with something that
I think today is probably the first
that we've ever really talked
about this yet is powers.
So Kiro Powers is a little bit,
they're like MCP on steroids if you will.
You get a little bit more than just an MCP
when you're trying to,
like you have an MCP file,
you have several of them,
you're not sure when you need them,
when you don't need them.
You'll maybe want to augment that
with some rules and steering files.
But with Powers it combines
those all into basically one.
So you'll get, and we have some
recommended ones here as well,
but you can create your own,
you'll see a bigger list in
the actual released version
that will come out.
I think it actually was
available this morning.
But for this particular project,
I'm gonna build something that
I'm gonna use Strands for.
So I can just go to the directory,
include the Strands Power,
and now I've enabled Kiro
with the information it needs
in order to help me build
this Strands driven power.
So I'm gonna build a project
here, I'm gonna show you,
this is Kiros on, this
is my fake retail site
that I built for my demo
and I want to add a customer
support agent to this
using Bedrock and Strands.
So, I'll just jump into Kiro
here, I'll give it a prompt.
In the past I might have
to be very, very careful
about the prompt that
I'm giving my AI agent,
but here I'm gonna do fairly simple
because I'll get a chance to refine this
and work through this.
And I wish my play dude
would disappear, but okay.
So Kiro will go off, examine this prompt
and create a requirements document for me.
This is an MD file. I'll be
able to share this with my team.
So a chance to review
this with stakeholders,
go back and forth a little bit
and iterate on the requirements for this.
And then if I need to
make some updates to it,
I can do that.
And so, I'm reviewing these requirements
and just kind of for the sake of demo,
I'm noticing something missing.
I wanna make the window
movable and resizable.
So I could do this with just
adding the text in there,
but in this case I'm gonna ask Kiro
to add this to the requirements
so that I can then go ahead
and when it builds it,
the window will be movable and resizable.
And when I'm happy with
those requirements,
I can just click this button here
and we're gonna move
on to the design phase.
So Kiro's gonna analyze what it saw there.
It's kind of figuring out
that I wanted to do
something with Strands.
And so, it's gonna do a little
research in the background
and here it activated the Kiro Power.
And what the cool thing
about these powers,
if you're using an MCP server,
it might get loaded all the time,
but here, this is on when it's needed,
it will load this power
because it knows from what
it's working on the context
that it's gonna do something with Strands.
It'll deliver this requirement
design document for me.
I'll get some diagrams,
I'll get pseudo code in here
and then it does this other neat thing
that's these correctness properties.
So this is a set of properties
that it derived from the
requirements to kind of validate
and tie everything together
to help us get back
to make sure that the
requirements that we're building
match what we asked it to.
So it's another way for
it to do some testing
and reasoning to make sure
that it's getting things right
and it's also really useful for you
when you're reviewing the design
to make sure that it covered everything.
And I noticed that when
I was covering this
that I would like a
little bit more robust.
I talked about input validation,
but I wanted some more robust validation
to make sure that there
was no toxic content
getting into my agent,
so I went ahead and
asked Kiro to add that.
And then once I'm
comfortable with the design,
we move to the next phase
which is creating the
tasks for the project.
And it gave me this option
for if I want those tasks
to be all included or do
I want just some of them
to be optional or not?
And I chose optional for making
the demo a little quicker.
But you can see these things that are gray
are optional tasks and I will get an,
I can turn them on if I want to.
I can review this and decide,
okay, some of these I want
and some of them I don't.
For the demo that I'm gonna do here too
I also have all these tasks
and I wanna make sure that
they get synced up in Jira.
I know not everybody loved Jira
but it's a good way to
illustrate what we're doing.
(Sam chuckling)
It's a good way to illustrate
the work that we're going through here.
So, and also the power of the MCP,
which I think a lot of
you're already familiar with.
But within the IDE here I
can add this Jira MCP server
and we have, you know, authentication
so it logs into my credentials
and now I'm wired up to my Jira account
and I can go in here and just ask Kiro
to take all those stories and tasks
that it created in those files
and create stories and
tasks for me in Jira.
So this is a spot where I definitely
needed to speed up the video.
It took a little bit but we can go through
and it created eight user stories
and 19 sub-tasks for me all in Jira.
And so, now I can track these,
I can distribute this throughout
my team if I wanted to.
This is a pretty small
example for this demo,
but if you had a bigger project
and you maybe wanted to parallelize
some of this work throughout
your team, you can,
'cause here you can see everything in Jira
with the descriptions and
the details and all that
of what the project was doing.
But I might want to sync
this up a little bit
with the work that I'm doing locally.
So, Kiro has agent hooks
and so the agent hooks are a way for Kiro
to respond to events that
happen in your environment
and then call the agent and
take some action on your behalf.
So what I've done for the demo here
is I'm gonna set up a hook that will,
if anything changes in my
task file to check that
and then do the right thing
to update my Jira for me.
So I can describe this
in natural language.
I don't have like a whole
bunch of configuration clickies
that I have to do and it figured out
that it needs to monitor the task MD file.
It kind of broke down to
make sure that I'm clear,
I can iterate back and forth
with it about what I want
and I want it to like,
if I mark a task done,
make check to see is that
the last task in the story,
can I mark the story done?
And then it kind of updated
and kept track of that
for me in my task file.
And now that I'm ready to get working,
these MD files are embedded in Kiro
in a way that I can just click
on that little button there
that says "Start the task,"
gives me a little indicator
that tells me the progress of the task.
I can watch it in the chat
dialogue and see what it's doing.
If it needs permissions for
something it might ask me.
It kind of, I probably noticed
it was a little red there,
it found a, it kind ran into
an error but it figured it out
and moved on and kind
of built that first task
and gave me a summary of what it did.
Now as I mentioned,
there's 19 tasks in here
and I don't want to handhold them all.
I want to go get coffee.
I just told it to go ahead
and power through the
rest of 'em and I did.
I went and got a coffee and came back
about 15, 20 minutes later and here we go.
We've got all our tasks
completed with a summary,
a wrap up of them, it went to Jira,
it updated the status of those.
And just for fun, I'd like,
let me check the burn down chart.
There isn't granularity in Jira
that can show you what actually happened
because I got all those tasks
done in less than an hour
and that's the smallest granularity
in their burn down chart.
But I can go in and just in
like, look in my terminal here
and kind of show you that
we can see the code here.
It added initializing the Bedrock agent,
added the agent for us,
it 2,245 lines of code
and 18, over 1800 lines
of just documentation.
So it also updated all my docs for me
and here's my app and I
got a new button on my app.
I can ask it questions about my catalog
so it knows about my,
the API for my catalog
and is able to have searched
that and found what I had.
But it's not perfect.
The font is not in the color
that I can really read here.
It did a fairly decent
job picking up my styles,
but I don't think we had anything in there
for this particular issue which,
but let's just go back into Kiro
and see what we can do to fix it.
And this is where, like we can
just vibe code this one here.
We can click the vibe code button.
I'll describe the problem that I ran into.
Also the output from the
LOM there at the end.
That big block was just
a big block of text
but it's markdown so I'm asking it,
can you please format the markdown
so that we can get bullets and headers
and all that kind of stuff?
So it runs off and does that for me.
We can just refresh
the app here real quick
and see what it did.
I don't even have to really load it.
And there we go, now I can read it.
I got bullets and headers
and it looks pretty good.
But you probably noticed
I was talking over it,
it was very slow.
That was not right.
But that gives me a chance
to show you the CLI.
The CLI is, you know,
just in the terminal,
there's a ton of tools in it.
It's a little bit more hands held,
manual kind of environment
if you want to be a little bit more
interactive and involved, you know,
different tools for different folks.
I like driving a stick shift.
So for me, this is really
the world I like to be in.
I really like, I use this daily
for pretty much everything I do.
You can see the list of features
and a lot of experimental
stuff that's coming out.
If you're using this,
you should be checking the release notes
pretty much every other day or so,
they're using Kiro to build Kiro,
so it's just, it's just fast.
My job is to describe Kiro to you
and I'm learning things from people
'cause it's just so fast
that it's coming out.
One of the features is
this ability to do agents
and you can kind of bundle MCP files
and steering files and stuff like that
and you can switch those back and forth
depending on what you're working on.
So maybe you can say like,
you can bounce back and forth.
We're doing some kind of
agent core related stuff here,
so I'm using my agent core.
And I told it what I was experiencing
and it noticed that I didn't,
we didn't use the streaming interface
that we're blocking on
the calls from Bedrock.
So it went ahead and is making the update.
It's asking me if I want this showing me
the coding changes that it's about to do,
and I just went ahead
and approved them for the sake of this.
And then we'll come back in here
and I'm gonna ask it a
question again about my catalog
if it can go out there,
and you can see this time
it was a whole lot faster.
So there, that's a lot of stuff.
I went through a lot really quick
and I really could talk
about this all day.
There's a lot of really
cool features within Kiro
that you'll see if you play
with it and experiment with it.
Just neat little stuff like being able to
automatically generate
your comments for a commit.
You know, you click the button here,
it knows what the context
is, what the chat has been
and can create that message for you.
We recently added check pointing as well
so that if the agent just did something
that you kind of don't
like and want to go back,
you can revert that
checkpoint and take it back.
And things, like I said,
things are coming out pretty
much on a daily basis.
So to get a real deep dive into this,
there's some other sessions
at re:Invent that I would recommend.
Just go find those, come
see us at the kiosk,
but more importantly
download it, play with it.
Let me know what you think.
And I'm gonna give this back to Rory here.
She's gonna close it out
with some more information
on how you can learn more
about Kiro and get started.
- Awesome!
- Thanks.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)
How do I switch it back to
presenter mode? This one?
Oh nice. All right.
So getting started with
Kiro is pretty darn easy
as far as you know, downloading it.
There was an Easter egg in that demo
that I don't know if you
were paying attention,
but it was Kiro Powers.
Kiro Powers is available today.
It was an embargoed session,
so if you wanna learn
more about Kiro Powers,
I would recommend going to
Kiehl's session DVT 228 tomorrow
to learn more how to get,
what did you call it?
MCP servers on steroids.
Yeah, well, I don't think
that's our official marketing line,
but it is a way that we can accelerate
the sort of connective tissue,
especially with other AWS
services like Agent Core.
So thank you very much for
attending this session.
We would love to hear
more about what you like,
what you don't like, because like I said,
our development cycle has
been greatly disrupted.
Take Kiro Powers.
I don't think we had anything
planned for Kiro Powers a month ago
and we went from inception
all the way into production
to launching it at re-Invent
in under four weeks.
And that's actually
pretty slow for us now.
So, these technologies
are massively disruptive,
not only to our own internal processes,
but I hope they get to
disrupt your processes as well
and give you the opportunity
to do more faster
and put more human in your projects.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)